hello and
welcome to the spectators alternative
conference my name is kate andrews i'm
economics correspondent at the spectator
you're watching this on spectator tv
where the conference over the next three
days is being hosted and
this morning is our economics morning
which is
very kindly hosted by barclays this is
the first panel
of our digital conference recovery from
covid how the uk can generate
jobs and growth and of course we know
that the covid
19 crisis has created the biggest
economic contraction in the uk
in 300 years the worst of any major
economy
more than 9 million workers at the
height of the jobs crisis were
furloughed with many still at risk
of permanent unemployment while the oecd
predicts that britain will suffer
some of the worst economic damage of any
developed
country of course it's those who are on
low pay
still very vulnerable that may suffer
the most from this
economic fallout now the government has
set out a three-phase plan to secure
economic recovery so far it's included
160 billion pounds worth to get us
through this crisis to get us through
the height of it paying almost 12
million people's wages supporting and
subsidizing
business and the chancellor has re
recently promised to create
new shovel ready projects to focus on
green
energy a green economy and training for
young people
but i think the question on my mind i'm
sure on many of our panelist minds and
indeed on the public's minds is is this
going to be
enough uh a lot of the policies so
far have been have been brought forward
including money has been brought forward
from the conservatives
previous manifesto but is it time to
throw the whole thing out and start
afresh
in this very new world that we're living
in roger i'm going to move over to you
to give your two minutes of opening
remarks and we'll come back to tasman
well thank you very much um yeah i want
to start off by saying something about
the current crisis and then how we get
out of it
let me begin by saying that i think that
the treasury
has done a fantastic job i'm not saying
that just because
jesse is there and he's done a fantastic
job in very difficult circumstances
and i recognize of course that
governments everywhere including this
one face a remarkable challenge in
unprecedented circumstances having said
that i think the first thing the
government's got to do
to get this economy right is get its
messaging right
about kovi and the way to tackle it
uh and this in essence this is not
straightforward economics actually it's
about
getting the the messaging and the
policies right the government's been
through the most amazing contortions
and if you're a small businessman or
even a large businessman particularly in
the entertainment sector
how on earth do you plan for the future
i really don't know in terms of concrete
steps the first thing i would do
is i put some economists on sage and i
might get rid of some of the existing
medicos from sage by the way
and get some actually skeptical educated
attitudes to modeling and predictions
now going forward
as we get out i think that the economy
will show
a lot of resilience it has done already
it's bounced back
quite a lot um i think the two things i
would say is first of all the government
in my view must refrain
from trying to bring the deficit and the
debt ratio down quickly
leave them uh let them take care of
themselves and these conditions i think
uh you know we can we have the time the
second thing to say
my point of view is i think that i would
resist
uh a lot of funny little measures
designed to boost jobs and growth and
i'm
a hs2 skeptic i'm afraid i think the
best thing the government can do
is lay out a framework for the future
and in particular a framework
with regard to taxes in my view the last
thing that the government should be
doing is contemplating
big increases thank you so much roger uh
tasman i think we have you back so i'll
hand it over to you
sorry i'm not sure how much of that
you've got
but i think yeah i did disconnect
apologies for that um
so um so as a uk head of the corporate
bank here at barclays i'm talking to uk
corporates up and down the country about
the challenges
that they're facing and how they're
navigating through the crisis
so that we can better support them we've
strived to support our clients and
customers
and throughout the crisis and to have
stood behind all of the
government lending schemes which today
means we facilitated approximately 24
billion pounds
worth of funding into the economy that's
super
unprecedented and you know that word is
um frequently used
um in the crisis but just to put that
into context
um we did three years worth of lending
um
in the first 12 weeks of the bounce back
loan and
that really is unprecedented you can
imagine the hard work
that our teams have to put in to process
these loans and
and they work tirelessly throughout
sometimes to very difficult personal
circumstances
um to to get that done and but it just
reflects the scale of the crisis and how
everyone came together
to support the economy because the work
we were doing was enabling
people to stay in their jobs in addition
to the government schemes we also put in
quite a broad range of other support
measures as well such as
repayment holidays free loans and
waivers
and things like that and of course we
did carry on with our normal mending
as well in fairly significant volumes
which
which gives me quite a lot of reason to
be optimistic
but as we know the crisis is not over
there is quite a lot of uncertainty
around a second wave of infections
as well as the uk's future relationship
with
europe and i think the combination of
both of these is really
creating a perfect storm for business
and so it is another time for corporate
britain
but we're listening and we're working
really closely with businesses to help
them work things through
thank you tasman at jessie norman
financial secretary to the treasury
let's have two or three minutes worth of
your thoughts
well thank you very much indeed uh kate
and thanks the spectator and to barclays
for putting on this uh
great economic and political jamboree
uh in virtual uh space but in real time
so thank you for that
um well i i and also thank you roger for
your very kind
remarks about uh the treasury i must say
uh you know talk about a pandemic to
bring out the best
energies of the civil service but uh you
know my officials
and those are the chance to achieve
secretary and other ministers
and in particular hmrc which is for
which i'm accountable within government
uh i think have just done a phenomenal
job
and uh if if someone had said we'd be
able to
get the kind of programs out that we
have done a very short notice
get the number of people furloughed and
supported through the um self-employed
scheme
and the other schemes and then most
recently to roll out this latest
wave of uh changes um you know
someone said that even a few months ago
it would have been regarded as
astonishing so to have done it
uh since march uh and under these
circumstances
while hmrc itself has been rescaling
leaving the office
uh and dealing with kobe problems of its
own uh is remarkable
i think you'll have seen that really
there have been
several phases the the furlough scheme
was
all about cushioning the impact of the
initial
shock on the economy and trying to
support people in their jobs and of
course across wider society businesses
and families as well across a much wider
array of government interventions now
what you've seen last week
uh is the latest response in between
which is the
the the support uh scheme and various
other changes we've made to uh
extend vat and uh the bounce back loan
schemes
but of course in between we also had
and this i think is a very important
aspect that people are apt to forget
an enormous amount of work on supporting
jobs
and uh the plan for jobs and and our
hope
is that as we get through as the economy
mutates and develops
we will be able to make that transition
as effectively and as smoothly
as we can but as the chancellor said we
simply are not in a position as a
government
to try to uh prevent uh
or to be able to prevent um the kind of
uh
uh damage that we may see in parts of
the economy and we can't
protect every job or every business and
that's a complete
tragedy for the people involved but i'm
afraid it's the nature of being in a
pandemic crisis
of the kind that we are what we can do
is to work as creativity
as creatively and as energetically as we
can to
make sure that from a government
standpoint every possible support is
given to people
by way of education and financial
cushioning as they make a transition
into
the jobs market of the future thank you
jesse
and ray newton smith chief economist at
the confederation of british industry
some thoughts from you uh definitely
well well thank you and
and uh thanks to the spectator and
barclays uh for hosting us
uh this morning and and i think i i mean
i i almost
it's where sort of start a panel say i
really agree with what everyone's sort
of saying
um uh so far but i think maybe just to
give a few
quick reflections and i i completely
agree
i think the work that the treasury and
hmrc in particular have done
to do at speed and scale is not
something i ever would have expected
um to see in my lifetime but i think the
real challenge for the economy at the
moment
and and i think we knew this was coming
is now some of the decisions and some of
the choices i think get a lot harder
i think in the initial phase of the
crisis everyone recognized
we needed to use the financial system to
build a bridge to the other side we
wanted to almost preserve the economy as
it was and just
get it over to the other side of this
crisis
and the other thing we absolutely needed
was a mechanism to support
employment to support people's jobs and
and to really minimize
any uh unemployment in that initial
phase of the crisis
i think the challenge is we're now
moving to the second phase and
and we there's two big challenges right
we're seeing a rise in infection rates i
think
the second wave that we all worried
about
has maybe come a bit earlier and maybe
with a bit more ferocity than
some people had expected and i think
that's come as a shock to
to all of us and then the second
challenge is
is to what jesse was saying we can't
save every existing job and every
existing
company and that's a really tough
message particularly as this crisis
plays out over
over time but what you are now trying to
do is get some of that dynamism back in
the economy and there are
and the other challenges there are
absolutely businesses that are growing
there are
you know even towns that are thriving
though there are some city centres that
are really struggling at the moment and
this is the challenge there are some
within each sector there are some
businesses that are doing well at the
moment and there are some that are
having such a tough time
and that is because of the fallout of
the health crisis but it's also because
it is changing people's patterns of
behavior and it's accelerating trends
that were already out there from
the move to um uh you know shopping
online as well as
changing uh more flexibility in people's
working pattern and i think
how you use uh government policy to
soften some of that transition but still
allow some
um transitions to happen is the real uh
challenge that we face
and i think you know if i were talking
about
uh you know if i've been talking at this
this panel maybe last wednesday
i would have said what we need to see is
um is a successor to the job retention
scheme i think we now have it
um you know it's easy to say it's not
perfect but then the world isn't isn't
uh perfect either i think there is a
live conversation as to
you know the hope is that will help to
transition as many people
back into the place of work uh over the
medium term while
being cost effective but i think the
chancellor may need to do more on that
at some stage
but i think we need to see how this
scheme works i think the second big area
was around pressures on businesses
cash flow and we did see some important
moves around that deferring bat and
extending the loan schemes from
you know repayments over six ten years
versus six years is huge to a lot of
businesses and i think there was a lot
of detail
last week that kind of got lost in um
some of the other measures that i think
were really important
um but i think you know thinking to that
long term the the area where we want to
see
the government invest where they already
have it is about
the move to low carbon economy i think
the measures in the summer around the
greens homes grants and
thinking how we can use this opportunity
to invest in our public
infrastructure that is really geared
towards that low um
transition economy whether that's you
know how retrofitting our homes whether
that's thinking about how we move around
the country the move to electric and
other low emission vehicles
and the whole future of mobility and and
i think also
you know moving ahead with some of the
big infrastructure projects that we know
we
we need to do i think those sorts of
things do give confidence
um to people and individuals over the
long term but
i am sure there will be plenty of
questions there's lots
to debate but i think that the challenge
for everyone now is
the very clear choices about what we
need to do for the economy
uh you know are no longer with us we're
now in this tricky
point about how do we flatten the curve
of unemployment there will be
an increase in unemployment um and
that's really challenging i think for
the economy because that's something we
haven't dealt with for
many many years now um and so i do think
the choices as we go ahead get really
difficult how do we
you know help don't put too much of a
burden on on a younger generation
um as we come out of this crisis and how
do we create opportunities
around the uk remain some of the biggest
challenges for our economy
thanks well we already have some
questions rolling in from our audience
but i'm going to abuse my position as
chair
to ask each of you just a question or
two um jesse
i'll come to you first the front page of
the times newspaper today
suggests that we could be looking at
significantly stricter
measures coming in to tackle the rise in
coven 19 cases there's
talk of banning household mixing and
even of shutting down the hospitality
industry for at least
two weeks a circuit break in that
industry
has the treasury held back its firepower
so that
if you were to shut down entire sectors
again
you could give them more generous
subsidies to get through that
or is the job support scheme the next
phase and now regardless of what happens
with code but there's no going back
well we are certainly committed to the
job support scheme and we will see that
through and it sits alongside a range of
other policies uh including the um uh
bonus and the uh
uh also of course the bounce-back loans
and the va
release and the other release we've
announced so and deferrals so
that policy framework is expanding and
uh developing one
but i mean the chances made perfectly
clear that
uh you know he uh i think his phrase was
uh is prepared to get creative when the
moment
uh demands it and we've just seen
that last week and so
you know who can say what the future
will bring i would say though that
it was quite noticeable that in its
commentary earlier in the crisis the
oecd pointed to the
relatively strong state of the uk public
finances relative to some of the other
countries uh
that it surveys as being a cause for uh
durability and resilience and
um that is in many ways tribute to some
of the good work that's been over the
last
done over the last 10 years and so we
certainly do have
firepower if we need it but we no one
would want us to use it if we
didn't have to well rain you were
calling for the government to extend or
create a new furlough
like scheme they have now brought in
this job support scheme
jesse's saying you know you don't want
to use the firepower if you don't have
to
do you think they've used enough this
time around
i i think that it's an impossible
question
to answer right now and i think as as
jesse would say in some sense we have to
see
what happens i think what the chancellor
needs to
to do is stand ready to act uh if if
necessary i think what i can tell you
from talking to
businesses both in the run-up to the
announcement on thursday and since then
is this absolutely
that um the work support scheme will
absolutely
help uh businesses you know whether it's
those manufacturers in uh in the
northwest who have said
look it this will allow them to keep on
more of their workers they were facing
you know have felt like they had to make
tougher decisions in the end
of october you know airports some of the
businesses that feed into uh that supply
chain
and this will really help a lot of
businesses through what will be a really
tough time
um i think the challenges and what we
are hearing that's been commentary
around this is in
you know in some of these sectors where
you have
uh you know i think what you want to do
is to try and help
uh you know really flatten that curve of
unemployment but that doesn't mean that
this will
it businesses do have to make a
contribution right to some of the
non-worked hours
um and i think that is important it's an
important test for whether you know this
you see a future to your business that
yes we're in this period where
demand is very weak because of the
social distancing measures and and
because of how we are dealing with
um this health crisis but it's not right
that the government is
you know is stepping in to save every
single job because some of the trade-off
as well is if
if the government is funneling in all
the support for those jobs there are
people who lost their job back in march
there are young people coming into
the labor market and i think it is right
that the government is also thinking
about how they
support those people so i think it's a
really tricky
balancing act it may you know it may
we may find out in a few weeks time that
the you know the chancellor needs to
take
more action but i think the other
challenge is i absolutely agree
what with what roger was saying at the
beginning that we can tolerate a higher
level of government debt we're in a
fortunate position where interest rates
are very low
um but i think we are also getting to
the stage where we do need to think
about the impact on our public finances
um overall and we need to make sure that
whatever measures we put in place are
targeted
at firms who really are struggling
because of this crisis
and not you know move away from some of
the generalized support
we will certainly come back to the
public finances uh but first
tavnim i wanted to ask or pick you up on
a point
you mentioned that barclays had given
out an unprecedented
number of business loans uh just in the
first few months of the covet 19
pandemic hitting the uk as we go into
the winter months and as it looks like
we're only going to get
more restrictions not fewer on how
businesses can operate and how we can
live our lives do you think there needs
to be stricter criteria
for the kinds of loans that are going to
be dished out to
business um so the the criteria that
um um were being used were
were fairly targeted i would say um
in in the first instance anyway um and
certainly on the seabulls
um and that we were having to follow
fairly strict criterias laid out by the
british
business bank around um affordability
because
certainly um we you know we would all be
concerned about businesses borrowing
more
and then they could afford um to pay
back
but but i think um you know as um
range just just highlighted um i think i
think
the support that was provided over the
summer
um kind of provided emergency funding to
kind of secure
the short-term um support that
businesses needed
um and what we what we found is that
um that's that's taken some of the panic
out of
um the immediate panic away from
businesses
and um some of the businesses have been
using that funding
um to pay suppliers um to secure
um to top up on the furloughs um
and but i think i think that there is
definitely a different differentiation
between
businesses that for which covid
is um call it a temporary
effect versus businesses that
even pre-covered were going through
their own
um kind of transformation um anyway and
needed
um to kind of keep adapting and
innovating and
and those businesses um you know will
need to continue
um to do that um you know using some
government support but also
um um there's support
from from from the businesses themselves
um as well i think one of my clients um
in the hospitality industry um
said something to me which is sort of
stuck in my head which is that
um covid and the crisis was never a time
to kind of
earn but it was a time to learn and
adapt and kind of
innovate and and i think the good
businesses out there have been
using um you know the crisis um in in
is a much positive way as possible and
really using these support measures to
kind of
really innovate and kind of pivot their
business um to
kind of new business models roger you
mentioned in your opening remarks and
and rain picked up on it that we
shouldn't worry about the debt to gdp
ratio right now treat this more as a
one-off wartime spend
it's not in theory anyway going to turn
into a structural deficit problem
but the job support scheme starts in
november and is going to last for six
months which brings us well into 2021 it
it looks increasingly like we are
increasing structural spending
so perhaps we don't care about the jet
to dd debt to gdp ratio but should we be
increasingly concerned about cost
ticking up in the years to come
oh roger you're on mute
um when i was saying earlier on that i
don't think we should be too worried
about the deficit and the debt ratio
that doesn't mean to say that i think
they don't matter at all there are some
people around who suggested that you
know
and there's a thing called modern
monetary theory that seems to suggest to
me
well they think anyway that um you can
go on having the central bank financing
this stuff had infinite but there's
never a problem now i don't
agree with that so you know the treasury
and the rest of us have got to keep a
weather eye on the
ratio um and yeah i think there are some
there have been some signs over recent
months uh
some conservative mmps and other people
actually with inside and outside
parliament
thinking that we've now got a free pass
and it doesn't matter we can let the
deficit do whatever it wants
that's not my view and i think uh
because we have got to
be concerned about the long term uh i
think we have to spend i think
various people have said this jesse
norman said it other people in the panel
said
we've got to brainstorm it we've got to
target
support and make sure that we don't just
splurge money
because although you know bank of
england buying this debt may give the
impression that it's free
eventually it's not i think this is a
difficult balance to strike i would not
be worried about the debt rate
i'll be more worried about um the point
you're making to make sure that the
structural deficit
shows every prospect of not coming down
now it's much too soon but
uh that we we can see into the future
that this is not going to be a problem
i think that's the big issue we're not
there yet
well jesse we have a question from
andrew speaking of that targeted support
who's saying what about the
entertainment and events industries
it's near impossible at the moment
anyway to see
when those industries can come back and
operate in a meaningful way
if your business essentially can't
operate or it is illegal to operate
because it's not possible to do so
without breaking social distancing
rules and guidelines set out by
government isn't there a case not to
wait to see how they fare but to give
more subsidy now
well uh thanks to andrew very much for
the question and of course i massively
feel the concern as someone who has been
involved in the arts in many different
ways for decades including as a
board member of the roundhouse in london
which uh was a product of my father's so
i completely understand i think the
problem is
um of course that we are in a
pandemic environment in which live
events in particular
and getting people together into the
same room
uh is extremely problematic and all the
more so in a
second wave now the government has
generally taken the view
that you know where where it has had to
uh impose social restrictions it is
appropriate to
try to provide support through the
economic system in many ways
uh as it can and it has done so of
course in the area that
andrew's talking about uh we announced a
1.6 billion pound support package
a few weeks ago which i i suspect was
probably
twice as large as anyone was expecting
at the time and was certainly
greeted with great acclamation and
relief by those
involved and its function was not just
to support the
the biggest anchor institutions across
the country
it was also to support the the local
institutions that are anchoring
individual communities
and the companies associated with them
so
that that is the main thrust of the
policy in this area so far
but of course many people who are um
in that sector can also benefit from the
other
schemes that we've put in place uh and i
know that many were
uh in the self-employment scheme or were
furloughed through other schemes
uh and uh hopefully we'll be in a
position to
to benefit uh if not directly now then
certainly
uh from the other schemes that we've put
forward going in future
uh rain risk rich has written in asking
about the generational divide
uh it was an issue or many thought it
was anyway before the kovic crisis we
were talking about intergenerational
unfairness particularly as it relates to
the housing market but in lots of
different aspects of life
and it seems that will be even greater
once we come out of this crisis
a lot of the calculations so far suggest
that young people are going to be most
likely to lose their jobs in the short
medium and long term
what can we be doing to mitigate this um
certainly from the economic perspective
what interventions do you think would be
possible but also is there any
area where we could perhaps roll back
some of our interventions to make the
economy a bit more free and to help
young people get a foot up on the ladder
so there's a lot uh in that that
question and you're absolutely right i
think before we went into this
crisis there was a challenge around the
experience of
of different generations and uh younger
generations partly because they
came into if you think about the
millennial generation came into
the labor market after the global
financial crisis
um often or at least some of that
generation and the generation after it
um and so what they they were already
experiencing some scarring effects
from that and lower pay at the age of 30
than than previous
uh generations um and and
because they entered the labor market
when i at a really tough time and i
think now you're you're going to see a
similar
generation entering the labor market
when
let's hope that you know we don't see
what we saw
after what paul johnson at the ifest
calls the dismal decade after the global
financial crisis where
uh pay growth was subdued almost for a
decade i hope that once we come out of
this crisis we'll see
a more rapid uh recovery but i think
what is clear is if you're leaving
university now if you're coming in
you are coming in at a labor market that
is tougher than we've ever
seen for many a generation uh in the uk
and and there could well be scarring
effects and i think
that's why you know the chancellor
announced in in the summer the
kickstarter scheme
which is a where the government will pay
for essentially
for any young person who's been
unemployed for a period of six months or
more
they will cover your wages um
for a six-month placement which then the
idea is hopefully that converts into a
job and it builds in a successful scheme
after
the last financial crisis but actually
even in wales they have something called
the jobs growth fund which is
quite successful they're getting young
people into employment
so i think we absolutely need to see
that scheme work i think one of the ways
you could make that more flexible
is and i think they've already altered
it a little bit is making it easier for
smes to
to do that i think um you know
originally you needed to have at least
30
placements offered as part of that
scheme you could come together with
other small businesses
but i think there's really something to
be said and we've heard it from some of
our members who've said look we'd love
to
do the scheme but realistically we're
only going to take on one person but
we'd love to give that opportunity to a
young person so thinking about how we
can really make that work for
smaller businesses i think would be um
great i think
the other thing we absolutely need to do
is prioritize keeping our schools open
and i think the government has come
around to understanding that i don't
um i think initially i'm not sure we saw
why that was so important to do as as
quickly as we could but now i think that
is a clear priority and that is
so so important um just because of the
scarring effects of
particularly lower income households
where they may not have the facilities
at home to do homeschooling in
in the way that other households have so
that's vital i think we do need to think
about
the experience of those at universities
but also the role of fe
colleges and and how we can make sure
that
they can sort of help with retraining
for for young people but also more
broadly so
i don't think there's any easy answers
to the intergenerational challenge but i
think we
i think it's important that we recognize
that yes the health implications of this
crisis are much more weighted to
the older generations and we really need
to protect their health but actually
the cost in terms of the labor market
and some and
and around mental health and lost
experience i think is really being born
by young people so i think we need
really need to think about that and bear
that in mind
and it is something that needs to be
considered as we're looking at some of
these
policies is how does this particular
policy you know
impact on uh you know people who are 60
and above how does it impact you know
people in their 20s i think we do need
to look at these and think about
uh the implications because it's
important for
you know how we come out of this crisis
tasnim what insight can you share with
us about
the the state of personal finance right
now
um there's reports that some people have
done
very well uh economically out of the
coven 19 crisis but many more
are struggling i'm thinking of young
people in particular many of whom may
have just
gone into debt to go to university and
are now quite literally being held in
their
in their rooms on campus um but for
young workers as well i mean what are
the long-term implications for their
financial burden going into the future
as they perhaps have lost their job or
struggling to save
and and how can we help to support them
and
and mitigate that pain
so i think one of the things we're
really proud about
at barclays is that we have continued
with our apprenticeship programs
which have been going for for a few
years and we have continued to recruit
graduates
um onto all of our schemes um and we had
over 1 000
um interns joined just um this summer
actually which is is um you know a
number we're very proud of
um i think um you know it's it is fair
to say that the impact
um on young people um only time will
tell actually as to what the what the
real
impact is um i mean some insight i can
give you is that even
some of our younger people here at
barclays um
you know we're having to go above and
beyond to make sure that
they get the full kind of experience
because when you're working from home
in a solitary environment it's really
hard to kind of learn because
um you know i used to be a graduate at
some point joining you know knowing
nothing
and you you learn a lot by being part of
a team
by watching others by you know people
kind of taking you under their wing and
you know those kind of experiences even
for the young people that are in work
right now and are kind of not happening
um
and and then of course um you know with
with with businesses closed or whatever
there's just less opportunities
for people to going to go into um
on your point about sort of personal
finance i think um
as you mentioned it is um i would say a
story of two halves in that
you know clearly there are some people
that are really struggling um
you know the furlough payments whilst
good is quite restricted in terms of the
amount
um that can be claimed under furno and
you know
who knows what commitments people may
have for mortgages and things like that
it might just not
be enough to pay away but equally
there are other people who um perhaps
you know would have spent a lot of money
on a holiday
and were unable to take it and have been
able to kind of save a lot
of money as well and then that's you
know we're sort of seeing
um money in in deposit accounts kind of
rising quite significantly
um as as well um and that's i think it's
a story of kind of two halves
kate well there's talk now of the
k-shaped recovery
some doing very well and some doing very
early out of this crisis and that that
is actually one to
one to look out for roger we have a
question from peter who's asking why
aren't the more innovative and
entrepreneurial businesses being
rewarded
for how they adapted during the crisis i
guess the first question is do you agree
with peter that
they're not being rewarded or recognized
and if we wanted to reward them more
why do we keep hearing briefings about
potential tax rises in the future
shouldn't we be
giving these businesses that adapted tax
cuts
well i've got a lot of sympathy with
that view
although i don't like the idea of
specific rewards that's to say
you know the government sits there as a
headmaster looking at the
class and thinking about which are the
jolly good pupils right yes we're going
to help you along
i don't think that's the way it should
be at all um but i absolutely agree with
the sentiment that the questioner
expressed about taxes now maybe you know
across the board tax cuts i don't think
we're quite
in the territory for that but i
absolutely agree that the
i mentioned it before uh not that many
weeks ago there were lots of stories in
the press we don't know quite where they
emanated from but there was speculation
that they emanated from very high places
in the treasury um that they were going
to be a raft of tax rises
uh before very long and it was going to
include increased
taxes uh on uh increased capital gains
tax wholesale
other things that would have a serious
effect on business people and
entrepreneurs
and i think that's precisely the wrong
way to go
i think we need a forward-looking tax
plan
this is a conservative government i
think business would
benefit a lot need encouragement or
rewards i think it needs to know
where we're going it needs to be
competent that uh
people can keep the bulk of what they
justifiably earn the gains they make
that's the key thing and they're not
going to be clobbered
in the future by some raft of new tax
rises that's i think that what the
conservative government should be doing
jesse this is a conservative government
so surely you're in agreement with
roger that tax rises should not be on
the agenda especially for these
businesses that
innovated and made sure that supply
chains held up and that we were
supported throughout the crisis
well uh thank you kate for that uh
encouragement to um
discuss treasury tax policy in advance
of fiscal events
and still no uh we never do that and so
if i don't do it now i i also
would say that's another great treasury
policy never to comment on um
speculation about tax rises which is
endemic in
a uh a world of media that is as lively
and energized
as ours and of course energized heavily
in part by
the spectator so um i'm not going to
comment on that either i do think
specific rewards for entrepreneurial
businesses from government
uh is a is an appalling idea um and
uh i think uh you know recognition when
people have done
a great job is uh is is a wonderful
thing but the beautiful thing about the
um
our commercial society in our account
system is that recognition reward comes
by doing a good job
the market gives it to you and that's
what we should be encouraging um
so i don't accept that what's
interesting i take the point roger makes
about certainty and stability and of
course he's absolutely right that under
normal circumstances the more certainty
you can give people in their taxes
the more um uh you can allow them to
plan and planning is good because it
allows
uh investment and therefore the system
to
function more effectively and smoothly
um the difficulty of course is that when
you're in a pandemic
where uncertainty is off the charts and
uh you know your fiscal numbers are
going up and down like a seesaw
the idea of planning for more than a
relatively short period
is just not uh doable but what i think
is doable
and what we have done elsewhere uh is to
think about what the structure of taxes
of our tax administration might be in
the longer term
and uh no one would have noticed it but
we published just for uh
uh summer a uh a 10-year plan for reform
of the tax administration framework
which is about the digitization of the
tax system
and um the use of data and
improving uh how hmrc interacts with
uh individuals uh digitally and
otherwise and that won't just improve
customer service hmrc
it'll make an enormous difference to our
resilience as a nation because we'll be
gathering information
uh in real time much more than we do at
the moment and
it'll also mean that we can very gently
give an
a kind of a nudge to businesses that
might be not quite as digital as they
should be through the tax system
to um invest a little more and once you
do that who knows where that
digital nudge might not need them in
terms of their own future productivity
and um well-being so there are things we
can do and we are doing many of them
but uh what we're not going to do is
start discussing long-term tax strategy
at this particular moment
well let me ask you this jesse the the
chancellor has postponed
the budget and replaced it with a winter
economy plan
uh surely because of the to your point
uh
we're simply not in a position to really
know what's coming down the track how
much more spending could be
needed and and and the consequences for
that but you speak of certainty
and uh whilst we cannot be certain what
will happen this winter with covet 19.
is the government in a position of
strength to deal with the uncertainty of
kova 19 and the uncertainty of a no deal
brexit at the same time
well i think the government is fully
capable of doing more than one thing at
a time and
uh this is a an environment in which uh
uh planned arrangements are coinciding
with unplanned
uh events and you know governments in
british history over the years have been
in um
uh turbulent times at least as turbulent
as these
and uh i don't think we will um
fail to rise to the challenge as the
moment comes i mean i think what i would
say of course is that
uh if you are um thinking about the
future
is a brave person who would say anything
other than that we're at a time what
john k and irving king called radical
uncertainty and uh
that isn't the same thing as risk and so
to make the mistake of
assimilating it to the normal risk
models is to make the mistake that
um uh many uh bankers have made and
tanzania will comment on this to their
to their sorrow and horror over the
years because they're not the same thing
as we discovered in 2008
let's uh move to the impact that the
kova 19 crisis has had on
workers specifically those who were told
to go home
rainn nigel asks how do you see
home and office work split and evolving
over the next five years uh surely this
crisis
as we've seen has not only encouraged
more people to work from home but has
really
moved things forward on that front but
do you see us if there were say to be a
vaccine or a silver bullet to cover 19
returning to the office in the way that
we did before do you think something's
changed
no i i think something has fundamentally
shifted and in some ways it's
accelerated a trend that
was already there in terms of more
flexibility and where it's possible
people working
um from home are having this sort of i
would call a mixed mode approach because
i think it's also shown us
uh some of the challenges when you don't
see your colleagues from months on end
and that's also a really tough place uh
to be so it is this balanced mode and i
think the
the first thing i'd say is what we're
talking about is the 35 40
of the economy where it's relatively
easy to work from home professional
services i.t etc and i think we have to
recognize you know
key workers who and many others in
manufacturing and elsewhere who need to
to be in a physical place of work to do
that to do their job
um but of that 40 percent of the economy
um what we're sort of finding from from
businesses is they're saying look
over the medium run we think you know
the overall capacity we need in terms of
office space is probably seven
you know around 70 of of what it was and
i think
it you know in general people are are
thinking about a mixed mode yes there
may be some people
in those uh businesses who who go into
the office
every day maybe because you know
particularly younger people
as well maybe in shared accommodation uh
we're being in the office
um you know it's beneficial to them
working effectively but i think you'll
find
the majority of people will have a mixed
mode maybe coming into the office a
couple of days a week
working from home the other period of
time
um and i think what we have seen and i'm
sure tasnim can
can speak to this and i absolutely know
from what we've seen in financial
services i mean they truly went
overnight um to being able to function
from home which was amazing
um uh but i think it's also showing you
know what has been possible and that's
happened across a range
of sectors so i don't think we will sort
of go back it has on the positives it's
really helped kind of digital adoption
you know the way we're doing uh this
virtually there's so many examples of of
how businesses have
used some of the digital technologies
that are out there to to keep their
teams
uh connected but i think it has also
shown you know it is hard to
collaborate with the team creatively
when you're all
uh separated people miss just seeing
each other and and being able to make
those very human connections that's
harder to do
over zoom so i don't think the office is
dead
it won't die it will come back uh you
know once this health crisis
is behind us but it will come back in a
very different way to to where it was
uh before uh absolutely well
tasnim it would be very interesting to
hear your experience working with
companies especially those struggling
how you think they've
adapted to working from home and
obviously the
the larger companies the ones with more
resources surely had an easier time of
it but perhaps those smaller companies
did
struggle quite a bit and people seem to
be um
quite passionate often about where they
fall on this those who want to come back
to the office those who think that home
working is
is the future so how do you think
businesses are going about having those
conversations right now
um so i think i i totally agree with the
point that rain was just making
um the role of the office i think has
changed forever
going forward um i think um
you know having particularly in sort of
you know standard kind of
office roles i'm gonna say um having
five days a week
um in the office i think is just not
gonna gonna be happening
um going forward um i mean we
we as well as our clients um literally
at a flick of a switch
um on march 23rd went from almost
everybody in the office
to everybody at home um pretty much
and um i think we sort of probably
surprised ourselves that
um how effectively we were able to do
that and stand that up
and particularly you know if i think
about
the heavy workload we had with all the
government scheme work that needed to be
done
exactly in parallel as as setting up
people
from home um i mean it was kind of
amazing
really reflecting back on it what um
what was achieved
i mean there were certain roles um that
we would have in the past kind of
thinking designated as 100
office based roles um even though we've
really suppose
you know supported dynamic working for
many years but even those roles um
were actually quite fine um working for
kind of working from home and so i think
it's it's really made us think about
um what the role of the office is going
forward i think
it's not going to be a place where you
go to do your solitary work
it will be there far more for
collaboration for meeting in big groups
and training and developing people
and then the other thing and just from a
client and customer perspective
um i i think the digital adoption
that um was accelerated through this
period
was was was really you know fantastic
um and um you know clients that
were sort of uh thinking about becoming
a bit more digital
you know using technology such as
docusign
as an example moving away from web
signatures
um and you know if i think about some of
um both our internal processes as well
as processes that our clients have
there's a lot of physical signing that
that
that we do that kind of delays things
and all those things became kind of
instant
um with leveraging some of these
technologies and so i i think um
um it did accelerate a um
a trend that i think is going to be
permanent um
you know feature for all of us and and
but i think the the office is not
not dead um as a place i think you know
that it will have
a significant role but it will not be
what we're used to
roger tasman makes an a very important
point there that
this has been that big push that some
companies needed to
embrace uh digitalization and
this may well improve productivity
across the board in the uk
however perhaps the flip side of that is
that as things move online
and not in every case but certainly in
some cases employers may realize
where they can make efficiency gains and
that might actually mean fewer employees
well in the short term it might mean
pure employees but you know
the system has a way of coping with that
people lose their jobs
other jobs are created i agree with you
i think there are positive sides to this
ghastly event and we will see increased
productivity
um but we can't tell in advance um this
is the sense in which
going back to what jesse and i was
saying about treasury not being able to
keep every job going or every sector
every business going
it shouldn't try because um
this is if you'd like a pure in some
ways it's a pure high
hierarchy an event in that there's a
major structural change going on in the
economy
and we none of us know how it's all
going to pan out frankly
this business of office working and
effects in a location where you're going
to live it
affects the need for commuter networks
the need for retailing it affects
entertainment food industry it affects
everything
and i think we have to painful but i
think we have to wait and see
what people want to do and in the end
we'll find out the market will tell us
people's preferences
will tell us but that's going to i think
it's going to affect
massive structural change and going back
to the beginning of uh
this session is one of the reasons why
this is just not an
ordinary downturn by any manner or means
it's not just a shortage
it's actually affecting massive
structural change
and we don't know quite how all that's
going to pan out i think the treasury's
approach so far is basically right
it's done the right thing with regard to
affording jobs
it's been pretty generous in the amounts
but what i don't think it should be
doing is saying right we must give a
whole load of support to
uh you know the provision of food or
inner city working or what or whatever
because
we just don't know how these sectors
frankly are going to be in the future
and the product the future productivity
of the british economy depends upon
us not keeping going dead sectors
and dead firms it depends upon a certain
amount of flexibility and dynamism
jesse to rogers point there the economy
has to be allowed to change as people's
preferences change as the way that they
demand goods and services change that's
very hard to know however in the midst
of a pandemic
which i suppose speaks to the the
furlough scheme and and the job support
scheme
um but at what point especially if a
vaccine does not appear to be as
quickly on the horizon as i'm sure many
in government and all of us would like
it to be
at what point does the treasury and and
other bodies in the government say you
know what
we just have to let the economy start to
adapt now and we need to stop trying to
hold on to the way it was before
well in many ways uh kate the treasury
has made that acknowledgement
already i mean last week was a clear
recognition
that we would move um
from a situation in which uh which i
think
andy held and held ended characterized
you know
a system of life support to a system of
uh job subsidy which
does allow us to support
uh change in the market economy and and
as roger says
i mean markets are fantastically
flexible
things and there are many many jobs out
there at the moment that would never
have been imagined
dreamt of even 15 years ago
and they will of course in 10 years time
15 years time be the same jobs and
um the astonishing thing about the last
10 years has been
the flexibility and the effectiveness of
the
british labor markets and that uh has
allowed an astonishing growth of in many
ways
um actually quite good quality uh
employment
it's often underestimated how good the
employment has been the
caricature is that everyone's on zero
has contracts that's simply not true
majority of jobs have been full-time
jobs so there will be a tremendous
amount of further
change and we have to allow the energy
and the resilience and the genius of
um people and businesses and families
and
to to adapt to the situation and not try
to freeze them in some
cryogenic suspended animation because
although that is appropriate
when you're looking at the first shock
at thinking about
how you deal with this astonishing
impact
and process of change people are
resourceful they do change they adapt
and
they're already doing that very rapidly
as we've seen now just to pick up some
of the themes that have just been
touched on
rightly so um i would worry very much
about
the impact of working from home on what
you might call
normal breakthrough processes of market
development young people
you know elbowing their way through the
door saying believe me have i got a
great idea for you
and you need to how about this because
what it really means is that people are
operating within their own often with
their own technology bubbles and the
kind of charm and energy that
the system relies on to promote new
ideas and new schemes
doesn't seem to exist in quite the same
way but that too will
that too will evolve and we have to try
to find
ways of making even the system we have
as it develops
as permeable to new ideas as open as
energizable
uh and as productive as it can be and
one of the things that
we're out to do is just forget the past
i mean even the
uh crisis of 2008 was very unlike the
crises we had in the 1990s was a balance
sheet recession where the bottom fell
out of
value across the economy in a way that
wasn't it wasn't a p
l classic uh uh as it were recession of
the kind that we'd seen in the 80s 90s
so there are differences there and one
of the things that we need to do as
policymakers is
constantly be refreshing our
understanding of the present by thinking
about the past
and then trying to speculate
imaginatively
hopefully without spending too much
public money in speculating about what
the future might be and how
we can support it and i absolutely don't
think we should be
backing the as it were the hypothetical
winners of the future but i think one of
the things we can do
is be really proactive and energized
about supporting technologies we know
are right on the cusp of development and
that's one of the things that we'll be
doing
uh i'm sure in the next few years and
that we'll be discussing in our national
infrastructure strategy when we publish
it later this year
we only have two minutes left so truly
30 seconds from each of you just to go
around
um looking to the winter uh you know
being realistic about the situation
seeing the direction that the wind is
blowing
what is um a support scheme or a
rollback or some kind of change or
intervention that you think could help
get us through the next phase of the
crisis rain i'll start with you
so i i think just just be prepared to be
agile
uh as as we have been and and
you know evolve the job support scheme
if we have but i think we do need to be
in this evolution of supporting people
in work supporting job creation
rather than just trying to preserve the
economy as it was back
in in march um and i think also think
about the no regrets action i know it
isn't the time for
tax rises but you you know we could be
consulting about fuel duty about the
alignment between employment and
self-employment about
the the challenges from business rates
uh you know there's so many things this
crisis has shown
you know we know we need to consult and
change over the medium term we could get
on
and and consult uh on those um
and and i think finally you know uh
probably remiss if i don't sort of
mention
brexit i think look there's been some
really good signs recently and noises in
the last few days about getting a deal
let's hope we get absolutely get a deal
because i think
for businesses trying to you know build
up stockpiles at this time as we head
into winter is just
really really challenging so i think we
all have our fingers and toes crossed
that we get that deal
across the line and and soon so
businesses can really focus on creating
that dynamic economy that we want for
the future and looking to the
the wide world as well tasnim
so i think the most important thing for
me um
from a business perspective is we we
need to find a way of
um getting confidence back um in our
businesses um here in the uk
um and to create as much certainty
as as as possible and you know i know
it's a
broken record around yeah probably sound
like a broken record around
um um the future relationship with
europe
as well as a pandemic but as much
certainty as we can build around
how that will all play out will just
enable
businesses to plan for the future um
in the short the medium and the long
term and we need to kind of encourage
businesses to start investing again
um and they will only invest if there is
confidence
and they can kind of see a path um to
realizing the return on their
investments
i think having some of the transitional
measures some of which have already been
announced which i do welcome
um so there's no kind of cliff edge that
businesses feel whether
you know um i think it's very welcome
that there was no clear fed for the vat
um and that you know furlough has been
replaced with something else
um and so i think yeah those kind of
measures are i'll just help him provide
that
kind of transition and you know i think
through
um the next couple of months um any
anything more that could be done to
build that confidence i think is going
to be vital
roger yes if i just briefly pick up on
the brexit issue
i'm of course a brexit here and i'm
enthusiastic about
us leaving even if we leave without a
deal although i
hope we do get a deal i don't actually
think it matters a great deal is one
thing i would
say if we don't get a deal um rather
that one than not have one
but i think this um pandemic has shown
pretty clearly how
comparatively irrelevant brexit is in
the immediate short term frankly
it's on a different order of magnitude
for the short-term impact compared to
the pandemic that's the really big
economic issue before us um when come
back to tax briefly
i accept what jesse norman said about is
hardly the time for the treasury to be
announcing
uh you know a tax plan but i'm conscious
and i've
written about this many times in the
years before the pandemic
the treasury didn't have a forward
backed plan either uh
apart from apart from uh i think
helpfully announcing forward plans for
corporation tax
now contrast this with what it did with
government spending
the treasury's had obtained plans even
though there's economic uncertainty it's
laid down
what's going to happen to government
spending overall to government borrowing
you go back to mrs sanchez government
they laid down
detailed plans year after year what was
going to happen to government borrowing
it was the tax burden and particular
taxes that squared the circle that was
just left to
fend for itself i think the treasury
needs to reverse that i think it needs
to start with tax
and jesse well uh i'm very grateful to
roger for that uh
stirring ending and uh uh i think um
some of the points he makes there are
well aimed
uh i would say this uh uh listen the
treasury has put a lot of policy out in
the last few days
let alone the last few weeks so i'm not
going to comment on new policies for the
winter
my focus actually is going to be
something slightly different which is
just to try to make sure that the entity
for which i'm accountable hmrc and the
national infrastructure strategy which i
was supposed to be responsible for and
uh
other parts to the territory and its
officials
are in fighting fit good order
well-rested energized enthused um
and and and hopefully able to have some
sleep after their energies the last
few weeks because we need those
organizations to be operating at
absolutely peak fitness and
effectiveness and we're going to
continue to need them to be in that
situation
and in that form for the next few months
and so um
it's not a policy that i'm going to be
focusing on it's it's the overall
fitness and energy of the teams because
that's what's going to determine our
capacity to respond to
change in a really agile and effective
way
well i'm very sorry that we can't thank
our panel in the usual way but i hope
that everybody watching at home will
join me
in thanking tasnim rayne jesse and roger
for some fascinating insights about
how we eventually come to recover from
this kovic crisis and how we can boost
the economy and thank you again to
barclays for sponsoring this panel and
this morning
if you're watching at home go grab a cup
of coffee grab a glass of
water because in 10 minutes we'll be
heading into our second panel also
sponsored by
barclays about global trade the uk's
trade plans after
brexit featuring trade secretary liz
truss so
thank you so much to our panel for
joining me thank you to
our watchers and stay tuned on spectator
tv